Back when Cliff worked as a room service waiter at Holiday Inn, so many guests ordered in pizza delivery to avoid the lousy room service. But sometimes the food and beverage manager, who was this tightly-wound guy and immigrant from Algeria, would stake out the lobby and try to catch the pizza delivery guys and kick them out before they made it to the elevators. Then one day this food and beverage manager came up with a better plan-- to trick the guests.
当时克里夫在假日酒店当客房送餐服务员，很多客人都叫比萨外卖，以避开那糟糕的客房送餐服务。但有时食品与饮料部经理，那个精神高度紧张的阿尔及利亚移民，会埋伏在大堂，试图抓到比萨外送员，在他们到达电梯前就把他们赶出去。后来有一天，这位餐饮经理想出了一个更好的计划——欺骗客人。
The hotel got some cardboard pizza boxes and takeout menus that looked like they could've come from any delivery places you've ever seen. Each of them had a cartoon of an Italian chef with a moustache and a big hat. He was holding his fingers to his lips in the classic kind of "Mama mia, that's delicious" sort of pose.
酒店弄到了一些硬纸板比萨盒和外卖菜单，看起来就像你见过的任何外卖店的那样。每一个盒子上都印着一个留着胡子、戴着大帽子的意大利厨师的卡通画。他把手指放在嘴唇上，摆出经典的“妈妈咪呀，太好吃了”那种姿势。
This pizza place had a name-- Giorgio's-- but the menus didn't list any address. They did list a phone number. And the phone number was not an extension in the hotel phone system. It wasn't a room service number. It rang at this red telephone, an outside line that they installed on the basement wall right near the big institutional hotel switchboard that the room service operators normally use to take orders.
这家比萨店有个名字——乔治奥（Giorgio's）——但菜单上没有列出任何地址。它们确实列出了一个电话号码。而这个电话号码不是酒店电话系统里的分机。它也不是客房送餐服务电话。它响的是一部红色的电话，那是他们安装在地下室墙上的一条外线，就在客房送餐服务员通常用来接订单的酒店大型机构化总机旁边。
And to complete illusion, we were given stacks of-- you know those green checks that you get in diners, the waitress just fills it out by hand?
为了让骗局更逼真，我们收到了一叠——你知道那种你在小餐馆里拿到的绿色账单吗？就是服务员用手填的那种？
This is Cliff. So we were supposed to fill one of those out and tape it onto the box for just that finishing touch of verisimilitude.
这是克里夫。所以我们本应填好其中一张，贴在盒子上，作为最后的画龙点睛之笔，增加真实感。
And so how would it work? Somebody would call the number, and then did you have to answer the phone and say "Giorgio's"?
那么它是如何运作的呢？有人会拨打那个号码，然后你们必须接电话并说“乔治奥”吗？
Yeah. We soon realized that being an outside line, we were relieved from the standards of ordinary hotel courtesy. So it was all this, "Giorgio pizza!" It was like a platform for improv. Use these ridiculous sort of Vaudeville Italian accents. "What's the matter for you? Hey Louie, where's the driver?"
是的。我们很快意识到，作为一条外线，我们不必遵守酒店常规礼仪的标准。所以我们就会说：“乔治奥比萨！”这就像是一个即兴表演的平台。我们用那些滑稽的歌舞杂耍般的意大利口音说：“你怎么回事？嘿，路易，送货员在哪儿？”
I want to apologize to any Italian-American listeners right now on behalf of Public Radio in general.
我现在谨代表公共广播电台，向所有意大利裔美国听众道歉。
Absolutely unforgivable on any level.
在任何层面上这绝对都是不可原谅的。
A room service waiter named Kevin had a character named Luigi that he would play on the one. The captain of the room service waiters, Brandon, been a loyal company man until all this absurdity began.
一个叫凯文的客房送餐服务员有一个叫路易吉的角色，他会在电话里扮演这个角色。客房送餐服务主管布兰登，在所有这些荒唐事开始之前，一直是个忠诚的员工。
And he could do a really excellent sort of Sylvester Stallone croak, which I cannot. And he could also do Brando doing The Godfather, which he loved to do. And, you know, mumbling--
他能模仿那种西尔维斯特·史泰龙式的沙哑嗓音，我可学不来。他还能模仿马龙·白兰度在《教父》里的样子，这是他最喜欢做的。你知道，就是那种嘟囔着说话——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
And so, all right. So if I'm calling for a pizza and I say, like, hi, I want to get like a--
好吧。如果我打电话叫比萨，我说，嘿，我想来一份……
You're getting a serious runaround, is what you're getting.
你会遇到严重的推诿，这就是你会得到的待遇。
There were two flaws in the deceit, and they were pretty big flaws, Cliff says. One was the pizzas themselves. They were frozen, and they were the size of room service pizzas, not real pizzas from a pizzeria. Smallest just nine inches. A large was the size of an old vinyl LP.
克里夫说，这个骗局有两个缺陷，而且是相当大的缺陷。一个是比萨本身。它们是冷冻的，大小和客房送餐的比萨一样，而不是真正的比萨店出的比萨。最小的只有九英寸。大的只有一张旧黑胶唱片那么大。
The other flaw was the delivery outfit. Conceivably, the room service waiters could have just changed out of their polyester tux jackets and bow ties back into street clothes and then pretended to be pizza delivery guys. Or they could have stayed in uniform and told the guests that they had intercepted the pizza on the way up.
另一个缺陷是送货装束。可以想象，客房送餐服务员本可以脱掉涤纶燕尾服夹克和领结，换回便装，然后假装成比萨外送员。或者他们可以穿着制服，告诉客人在送餐途中拦截了比萨。
Instead of either of those options, though, the food and beverage manager chose--
然而，餐饮经理没有选择这两个选项中的任何一个，而是选择了——
A very strange garment, the like I've never seen before or since, which was sort of a kind of peppermint-striped apron. White with vertical red stripes. And it was huge. It was enormous. I was absolutely, you know, lost in this bizarre garment. And it came with a floppy hat made of the same basic fabric.
一种非常奇怪的服装，我这辈子都没见过，那是一种薄荷条纹的围裙。白色，带有垂直的红色条纹。而且它很大。真是巨大。我完全迷失在这件古怪的衣服里了。它还配有一顶由同样基本布料制成的软帽。
None of it looked like anything any pizza delivery guy in this hemisphere had ever worn. And all sort of protested that this is a terrible flaw in your illusion. Because we had just been in the room. The waiter, you'd go up and you'd deliver a six pack of beer. And then 20 minutes later, you'd be back with the same face--
这看起来一点也不像这个半球任何比萨外送员穿过的衣服。大家都在抗议，说这是你骗局中的一个严重缺陷。因为我们刚去过客房。送餐员刚上去送过六瓶啤酒。然后20分钟后，你又带着同一张脸回来——
To the same room?
去同一个房间？
But dressed as this-- I always thought of it as a rodeo clown costume. If you'd send me in as a rodeo clown when I'd just been there as a room service waiter, it's going to stimulate suspicion. Plus, it was humiliating to wear this ridiculous getup. And then it was so stupid. It was just done so badly.
但打扮成这样——我一直认为这是马戏团小丑的服装。如果你在我刚以客房服务员的身份去过那个房间后，又派我以马戏团小丑的身份去，这会引起怀疑。而且，穿这套荒唐的行头简直是羞辱。这也太蠢了。做得太糟糕了。
No matter if it was done badly. It was done just well enough, with just enough of the details right, the menus, the outside phone line, that it made lots of money, right from the start.
无论做得多么糟糕。只要做得足够好，细节足够到位，比如菜单、外线电话，它从一开始就赚了很多钱。
Did guests ever say anything indicating that they were onto the scam?
客人有没有说过什么表明他们识破了骗局的话？
People gave you weird looks. But only once did somebody completely tip their hand, and did somebody ask me. The guy, he's busy signing his name on the check. And he says, "So." And he sort of gives me a smile. He's not being confrontational. He's being sort of sardonic. And he says, "So just exactly where is Giorgio's Pizza, anyway?"
人们会用奇怪的眼神看你。但只有一次，有人完全摊牌了，问了我。那个家伙正忙着在账单上签名。他说：“那么。”他对我笑了笑。他不是在对峙。他表现得有点讽刺。他说：“那么，乔治奥比萨店到底在哪里？”
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, bait and switch. We have four stories. In some of these stories are people running the scam running the bait and switch, are unrepentant. In some they feel guilty, they feel contrite. But in all of theses scams, once you know it's a scam, you can't believe people try to pull it off with a straight face.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“诱饵与转换”。我们有四个故事。在其中一些故事里，实施这种“诱饵与转换”骗局的人并没有悔意。在另一些故事里，他们感到内疚，感到忏悔。但在所有这些骗局中，一旦你知道这是一个骗局，你简直无法相信人们居然试图面不改色地把这事做下去。
Our four acts involve a car, a fake valentine, a fake girlfriend, and treating people for the Lord Almighty. Stay with us.
我们的四个篇章涉及一辆车、一张假情人节卡片、一个假女友，以及以上帝的名义对待他人。请继续收听。
Act One Neighborhood Watch.
第一幕：社区守望。
We begin in Austin, Texas, with some people who want nothing more than the best for all concerned. Michael May tells what happened.
我们从德克萨斯州奥斯汀开始，那里有一些人，他们一心只为所有人着想。迈克尔·梅讲述了发生的事情。
Mark Douglas Ledford is 39 years old and plays in several punk rock bands. But don't let that give you the wrong impression. He's a Good Samaritan kind of guy. A tattoo across his chest reads, "To whom much is given, much is required." He owns his own home and has a day job. November 29, 2007 started off like any other work day.
马克·道格拉斯·莱德福德今年39岁，在几支朋克摇滚乐队里演奏。但别让这些给你留下错误的印象。他是个好撒玛利亚人类型的人。他胸前纹着一行字：“多给谁，就向谁多要。”他有自己的房子，也有份日常工作。2007年11月29日，像往常的工作日一样开始了。
It was a Thursday morning. I went to work. I came home, I pulled into the driveway, and there was a car parked on the curb near my driveway. I noticed that the windows were down, and the doors were unlocked, and the keys were in the ignition, and it was kind of a big dangly keychain. Like it looked like a girl's keychain. It had a bunch of stuff hanging off of it.
那是一个周四的早上。我去上班。回家后，我把车开进车道，路边停着一辆车。我注意到车窗是开着的，门没锁，钥匙插在点火开关上，而且那是一串看起来很晃眼的钥匙链。看起来像个女生的钥匙链。上面挂着一堆东西。
Something was off. Mark lives a few miles north of downtown in a ranch home that sits on a corner of a quiet street with only one house nearby. The only people who park on this stretch are Mark's bandmates when they come over to practice.
有些不对劲。马克住在市中心以北几英里的地方，那是一栋平房，坐落在一个安静街道的拐角处，附近只有一栋房子。在这个路段停车的唯一人就是马克的乐队成员，他们来排练时会停在这里。
And so I immediately walked across the street to my neighbor Sarah's house. And I knocked on the door, and I said, hey, do you have company over? I think they left the keys in the ignition over there. And she said, I don't know whose car that is.
所以我立刻穿过马路走到邻居萨拉家。我敲了敲门，说：“嘿，你有客人吗？我觉得他们的钥匙插在点火开关上。”她说：“我不知道那是谁的车。”
And when I went back by and looked at it again, it looked to me like something had happened. Like someone left their car abruptly. And I thought it was suspicious enough, I went in and I dialed 911.
当我回去再看一眼时，觉得好像发生了什么事。就像有人匆忙离开了他们的车。我觉得这足够可疑，就进去拨打了911。
It was not even like 10 minutes, and there was a knock at the door, and it was a police officer. They said, did you report this car? And I said, yeah, isn't that crazy? And they said, well, what's the problem? It's legally parked. And I said, well, the windows are down and the key's in ignition. And they said, well, you know, you'd be surprised what we see out here.
不到10分钟，就有人敲门，是个警察。他们说：“是你报告了这辆车吗？”我说：“是啊，这不奇怪吗？”他们说：“好吧，有什么问题吗？它是合法停放的。”我说：“好吧，车窗是开着的，钥匙插在点火开关里。”他们说：“好吧，你知道，我们在这里见怪不怪了。”
And I was just like, are you kidding me? And so my thought was, OK. Well, maybe it doesn't seem strange to you, but it seems strange to me. Can you contact the owner or can you do something? Because they seemed just reluctant to do anything.
我当时就想，你在跟我开玩笑吗？所以我的想法是，好吧。也许这对你来说不奇怪，但对我来说很奇怪。你能联系车主或者做点什么吗？因为他们似乎很不愿意做任何事。
And the officers' response at that time was, well, you know. People, they buy these cars and they don't get them registered properly. I guess I could do a cross check on it.
警察当时的回答是，嗯，你知道。人们买了这些车，却没有适当地注册。我想我可以查一下。
And at that point, I was frustrated. And I said, listen. I don't know what your procedure is. They say if you see suspicious things in your neighborhood, report them. I'm reporting it. And there you go. And the officer went back to their car and drove off.
在那一刻，我很沮丧。我说：“听着。我不知道你们的程序是什么。他们说如果你在社区看到可疑的事情，就报告它们。我正在报告。就是这样。”警察回到了他们的车里开车走了。
There's women's clothing in the backseat. And not just like women's, but like, a women's, like-- they looked like stripper clothes, and then men's work boots and rope.
后座有女性的衣服。而且不仅仅是女性的，看起来就像是脱衣舞娘的衣服，还有男士的工作靴和绳子。
This is Mark's girlfriend at the time, Asia Ward. She's younger than Mark, 21. A cute gothy girl with a thing for zombie movies. Likes to read books about serial killers. They both started to imagine all sorts of sinister scenarios.
这是马克当时的女友，亚洲·沃德。她比马克小，21岁。一个可爱的哥特女孩，对僵尸电影情有独钟。喜欢读关于连环杀手的书。他们俩开始想象各种险恶的场景。
Like some poor little stripper lady was taken from her work and like murdered, and this is her car. Because if that cop walked by, even if they weren't going to do anything about it, they could have at least been like, oh, yeah. Get right on that. And like, made us feel better about it, you know? Or said that they were going to investigate it, or looked at it, been like, yeah, this does seem kind of weird. Because it does! Like, if you think that that doesn't seem weird then there's something wrong with you! You know? That's a fishy situation right there.
比如某个可怜的小脱衣舞娘在工作时被带走并谋杀了，这就是她的车。因为如果那个警察走过来，即使他们不想做任何事，他们至少可以像，“哦，是啊，马上处理。”让你感觉好一点，你知道吗？或者说他们会去调查，或者看一眼，说“是的，这看起来确实有点怪。”因为确实如此！就像，如果你觉得这不怪，那你就有什么问题！你知道吗？这情况真可疑。
By the next day, Friday, neighbors are trying to worry, too, about the car. Sarah, the woman who lives across the street, even calls the cops again and sends Mark a text to let him know she's on the case.
第二天周五，邻居们也开始担心这辆车了。住马路对面的萨拉甚至又报了警，并给马克发了短信，让他知道她在跟进这事。
That night, Mark goes to play a gig in San Antonio. And when he and Asia roll back home around midnight, there's the car, still just sitting there with the keys dangling from the ignition.
那天晚上，马克去圣安东尼奥演出。当他和亚洲在午夜左右开车回家时，那辆车依然停在那里，钥匙晃晃悠悠地插在点火开关上。
So when I came home Saturday night, I expected the car to be gone. I expected them to have towed it away. And at that point, I was just like-- I had it. I was like, OK. We're going to figure out what's going on with this car. That's it.
所以当我周六晚上回家时，我以为车已经开走了。我以为他们已经把车拖走了。在那一刻，我只是觉得——我受够了。我当时想，好吧。我们要弄清楚这辆车到底是怎么回事。就是这样。
And I was like, well, there has to be insurance papers, business card, something in the car that'll let us know who the car belongs to, and maybe we can call them and tell them, your car's parked here.
我当时想，车里一定有保险文件、名片或者什么东西，能让我们知道这车是谁的，也许我们可以打电话告诉他们，你的车停在这儿。
And at this point we're thinking, there might be a dead body, someone bound and gagged, it's a crime scene. And I'm like, well, I don't want to put my fingerprints all over a situation like that. So I put some gloves on. I consciously go, I'm going to put gloves on so I don't leave fingerprints. And they're black knit gloves, and they have like a little skeleton screenprint on them.
当时我们心想，可能里面有具尸体，有人被绑住塞住了嘴，这是个犯罪现场。我当时想，我可不想在这种情况下留下我的指纹。所以我戴上了一些手套。我清醒地想，我要戴上手套，这样我就不会留下指纹。那是黑色的针织手套，上面印着一个小骷髅。
So I get the gloves, and I open the door, and I start going through the glove box. And I didn't see anything. And I was talking to Asia. She's standing on the sidewalk. And I'm saying, there's nothing in the glove box. I go through the console. And then I would get out of the car and close the door.
我拿上手套，打开车门，开始翻手套箱。我什么也没看见。我当时在和亚洲说话。她站在人行道上。我说，手套箱里什么都没有。我查看了中控台。然后我会下车关上门。
And then we were talking, well, should I go in the truck? OK, go in the trunk. And so I'd open the door again, and I'd go back in the car, and I got the keys out of the ignition. And I tried to open the trunk, and it was like when I'd stick the key in, it was like there's something jammed in the lock.
然后我们还在讨论，我应该去后备箱看看吗？好吧，去后备箱。所以我又打开车门，回到车里，把钥匙从点火开关上拔了下来。我试着打开后备箱，感觉当我插入钥匙时，好像有什么东西卡在锁里了。
And I was like, listen. I'm going to get a screwdriver. I'm going to open the trunk. If I break somebody's lock, I'll pay them back. You know, whatever. We're just going to get to the bottom of what's going on here.
我当时想，听着。我要拿个螺丝刀。我要打开后备箱。如果我弄坏了别人的锁，我会赔偿的。你知道，随便吧。我们只是要弄清楚这里到底发生了什么。
And you know, I mean, I don't know what to do. I just stuck the flat blade screwdriver in the keyhole tried to turn it, and it wouldn't do anything.
你知道，我不知道该怎么办。我只是把平口螺丝刀插进钥匙孔试着转动，但它一点反应都没有。
So he puts the screwdriver down and gets back into the car, and is digging through the center console. And he looks out the window, and he's just like, hey, Asia, is that a cop?
所以他放下螺丝刀回到车里，开始翻中控台。他向窗外看去，说：“嘿，亚洲，那是警察吗？”
And Asia was like, no. And I go, that sure looks like a cop.
亚洲说：“不。”我说：“那看起来确实像警察。”
And right about the time I say, I don't think so, out of nowhere--
就在我刚说“我不这么认为”的时候，不知从哪儿——
Get on the ground!
趴下！
OK, sure.
好的，当然。
Get on the ground now!
现在就趴下！
No.
不。
Get on it! Get on the ground!
趴下去！趴下！
No.
不。
Suddenly they were surrounded by cop cars.
突然，他们被警车包围了。
Hey, we live right here.
嘿，我们住在这儿。
Get on the ground!
趴下！
Asia, get on the ground.
亚洲，趴下。
OK.
好的。
And they tell me to get on the ground and I said no, and Mark is just like, get on the ground! Like, Asia, you need to get on the ground. Because I was so shocked! Like, I wasn't doing anything wrong. I was trying to help them out because they didn't want to do their job, is the way I was thinking, right?
他们让我趴下，我说不，马克只是说，趴下！就像，亚洲，你需要趴下。因为我太震惊了！我没做错什么。我是在试图帮助他们，因为他们不想做他们的工作，我是这么想的，对吧？
And I was like, get on the ground! They will shoot. You know? Like, get on the ground. And so she laid down on the ground. And it wasn't long. There were like six cops there, just like that.
我当时说，趴下！他们会开枪的。你知道吗？就像，趴下。所以她趴在了地上。没过多久。大约有六个警察在那里，就这样。
Don't move, don't talk!
不许动，不许说话！
And one of the police officers is like, you thought you'd go for a joyride! And then throws me in the cop car. And I'm like, dude, they thought we took the car? Like, they thought we stole this car and drove it around? And I'm freaking out.
其中一个警察说：“你以为你会去兜风！”然后把我扔进警车。我当时想，老兄，他们以为是我们偷了车？就像，他们以为我们偷了这辆车，还到处开？我吓坏了。
Mark and Asia are handcuffed and put into separate cop cars, still with no idea what's going on, and told to wait for a detective to show up and interview them. Finally, he arrives. Detective John Spillers.
马克和亚洲被戴上手铐，分别关进不同的警车，依然不知道发生了什么，被告知等待侦探赶到并审问他们。最后，他到了。侦探约翰·斯皮勒斯。
And he starts asking questions. And he asks, he says, do you mind if I record this? And he's like, you have the right not to say anything. And I was like, yeah, I don't care. I'll tell you whatever you want to know. Like, I haven't done anything wrong. I'm not hiding anything. Like, I'll tell you whatever. So he's like OK. And I was like, I don't need a lawyer or anything. So he turns on his recorder, and I tell him exactly what happened.
他开始问问题。他说：“你介意我记录下来吗？”他说：“你有权不说话。”我当时说：“是啊，我不在乎。你想知道什么我都告诉你。就像，我没做错任何事。我没隐瞒什么。就像，我会告诉你任何事。”所以他说好吧。我当时说：“我不需要律师或什么东西。”所以他打开了他的录音机，我告诉他究竟发生了什么。
Thursday night I was coming to visit him, and I was walking from the bus stop to his house, and I saw the car outside, and I was like, hey, is somebody here?  And he's like, oh, no, the car's been there since, I guess, that morning? And he said that he had called the cops and a [UNINTELLIGIBLE] officers did come out, but say the car wasn't reported stolen or anything and there was nothing they could do about it.
周四晚上我来看他，我从公交车站走到他家，我看到了外面的车，我就问，嘿，这儿有人吗？他说，哦，不，那车从那天早上就一直在那儿了？他说他报了警，确实有警察来过，但说那车没有被报告被盗或什么的，他们对此无能为力。
They said that they were going to have to talk with some witnesses about me going in the car. And I said, you don't need to talk to any witnesses. I'm telling you, I went in the car.
他们说他们必须和一些关于我进入车内的目击者谈谈。我说，你们不需要和任何目击者谈。我告诉你，我进车里了。
I mean, if you find out who owns it, you know, I would gladly pay for the repair of the lock.
我的意思是，如果你找到车主是谁，你知道，我愿意赔偿修理锁的费用。
What I think we're going to do tonight is, I'm going to verify some things from the office. What I will probably end up doing is examine the photos suspects for you and her. That way--
我觉得我们今晚要做的是，我要核实办公室的一些事情。我最终可能会做的是，为你们俩查看照片嫌疑人。这样——
In case you didn't catch that, Detective Spillers is calling them suspects and talking about interviewing witnesses. He says a neighbor reported them breaking into the car.
如果你没听出来，侦探斯皮勒斯称他们为嫌疑人，并在谈论询问目击者。他说是一个邻居报告他们闯入车内的。
[INAUDIBLE] who the witness was?
[听不清]是谁报的警？
Well, the person who calls in saying there's people out here.
好吧，打电话说有人在那儿的人。
Oh. Well, yeah, we were out there!
哦。好吧，是啊，我们在那儿！
I mean, as investigator, I have to do my job.
我的意思是，作为调查员，我必须做我的工作。
Oh, OK. Well, I mean, you don't even have to have a lineup. I'll tell you [UNINTELLIGIBLE] out here.
哦，好的。好吧，我的意思是，你甚至不需要安排认人。我会告诉你[听不清]在这儿。
Finally, after a few hours of talking with Mark and Asia, who explain everything, including the calls to 911, and after talking with Sarah across the street, the cops leave without arresting anyone. Asia said they even shook hands.
最后，在和马克与亚洲谈了几个小时并解释了一切，包括拨打911，并与街对面的萨拉谈过之后，警察离开了，没有逮捕任何人。亚洲说他们甚至握了手。
Yeah. All right, great. Well, thank you.
是的。好的，太棒了。好吧，谢谢你。
Thank you, ma'am.
谢谢你，女士。
But there's one thing the cops didn't tell them-- a crucial detail that made the whole thing make sense. The police had put the car there themselves. There were no witnesses, no neighbors who saw them break into the car, and for that matter, no victims.
但有一件事警察没告诉他们——一个让整件事都讲得通的关键细节。警察自己把车放在那里的。根本没有目击者，没有看到他们闯入车里的邻居，也没有受害者。
The car is what's known as the bait vehicle, and it was out with surveillance cameras and microphones assigned to lure and catch car thieves. The gear was in the truck, which is why Mark couldn't get in it with the key.
这辆车被称为诱饵车辆，它带着监视摄像头和麦克风，专门用来引诱和抓捕偷车贼。设备就在后备箱里，这就是为什么马克无法用钥匙进入的原因。
Police departments across the country use bait cars. It's even funded by major insurance companies. And that's because it's effective. The police can sit back and wait for someone to take the car. Then the suspect comes in for booking, complete with their crime preserved on videotape.
全国各地的警察部门都在使用诱饵车辆。它甚至由主要的保险公司提供资金。因为这很有效。警察可以坐下来等待某人把车开走。然后嫌疑人就会被带走立案，犯罪过程完整地保存在录像带上。
If this sounds like a setup, legally, bait cars are not considered entrapment. Just like it's not entrapment for an undercover cop to stand on a street corner dressed as a hooker. For it to be entrapment, the cop would have to egg you on, would have to suggest that you pay for sex or steal the car, and that's not what they're doing here.
如果这听起来像是一个圈套，从法律上讲，诱饵车辆不被视为诱捕。就像卧底警察穿着妓女的衣服站在街角不属于诱捕一样。要构成诱捕，警察必须教唆你，必须建议你进行性交易或偷车，而这并不是他们在这里所做的事情。
The Austin Police made 70 arrests last year using bait cars, and Mark and Asia were about to become another statistic. Around two weeks later, on December 17, Asia's birthday, the couple is woken up at 6 AM. There are flashlights being beamed into Mark's bedroom window.
奥斯汀警方去年通过使用诱饵车辆进行了70次逮捕，马克和亚洲即将成为另一个统计数据。大约两周后，12月17日，亚洲生日那天，这对情侣在早上6点被叫醒。手电筒的光照进了马克的卧室窗户。
I had stayed the night at Mark's house and then we hear banging on his door in the morning. And we wake up, and he goes and he answers the door, and it's two police officers. And he is just assuming that they're going to ask him more questions about the car, but they actually say, we have warrant for your arrest and we're going to take you to jail.
我那天晚上住在马克家，然后早上我们听到敲门声。我们醒了，他去开了门，是两个警察。他以为他们只是要问他更多关于那辆车的问题，但他们实际上说：“我们有逮捕你的令状，我们要带你去监狱。”
And he's like, are you kidding me? I felt really upset, you know? Like you're going in jail for what? And plus, it's early in the morning, so I'm just like, you're going to jail, like, what?
他当时说，你在跟我开玩笑吗？我感到非常难过，你知道吗？就像你因为什么而进监狱？而且，那很早，所以我只是觉得，你要进监狱，就像，什么？
They asked me if anybody else was in the house and I said, well, yeah, my girlfriend Asia. And they go, well, we have a warrant for her arrest, too. We were about to go get her, too. And I was like, what?
他们问我屋里还有没有别人，我说，好吧，有，我的女友亚洲。他们说，好吧，我们也有逮捕她的令状。我们也正要去抓她。我当时想，什么？
The officers show them arrest warrants for burglary of a vehicle, a charge that could land them in jail for up to a year. They're confused, arrested for something they didn't do, and they still don't know it's a bait car.
警察出示了逮捕他们的令状，罪名是车辆盗窃，这项指控可能导致他们入狱长达一年。他们感到困惑，因为没做过的事被捕，而且他们仍然不知道那是一辆诱饵车。
In the waiting room at the jail, Mark whispers "happy birthday" across the room to Asia. It's against the rules, and he gets thrown in solitary confinement. He's in there half the day, and he doesn't exactly handle it like a hardened criminal.
在监狱的等候室里，马克隔着房间对亚洲低声说了声“生日快乐”。这违反了规定，他被扔进了禁闭室。他在那里待了大半天，他处理这件事的方式并不像个惯犯。
I mean, they put me in some little isolation room for a while. And I was like, are you kidding me? But yeah. And I kind of lost my mind in the cell. They took all my clothes, and they gave me this jumpsuit, and they stuck me in a cell.
我的意思是，他们把我关在一个小隔离室里待了一会儿。我当时想，你们在开玩笑吗？但是是的。我在牢房里有点精神失常。他们拿走了我所有的衣服，给了我这套连体服，把我关进了一个牢房。
And they had these slippers, and when I would walk, they would go, [SQUEAKING]. And I thought that there was a cat somewhere in maybe the violation duct, and I was like, how did you get in there, little guy? Are you OK? I was, like, [BLEEP] losing it. And it was weird, because he would only meow whatever I walked around in the cell. Then I'd sit down, he'd get real quiet, and I'd be like, are you OK, little guy? I didn't realize until they like, they go, you're going to be released, and I was walking down the hallway, and I could hear the little [SQUEAKING] of the slippers. Yeah. I was tripping.
他们有那种拖鞋，当我走动时，它们会发出[吱吱声]。我以为通风管里有只猫，我当时想，你是怎么进去的，小家伙？你还好吗？我简直要[脏话]疯了。这很奇怪，因为他只有在我牢房里走动时才会叫。然后我坐下，他就变得非常安静，我会说，你还好吗，小家伙？直到他们说，你要被释放了，我在走廊里走着，我能听到拖鞋发出的轻微的[吱吱声]。是的。我当时神志不清了。
To be fair, Mark and Asia's case is very unusual. Bait cars are usually played in high crime areas to trap people who already have criminal records. In this case, it was part on a quiet street in a nice neighborhood, just blocks from a high school, right where dozens of kids walk by each day. The police were less likely to catch a hardened car thief and more likely to snare someone drunk or high or broke or bored who'd walk by and see the car just sitting there with the keys in it.
平心而论，马克和亚洲的案例非常罕见。诱饵车辆通常被投放在高犯罪率地区，以诱捕那些已经有犯罪记录的人。在这个案例中，它部分停在一个安静街道的宜人社区，距离一所高中仅几个街区，那里每天都有几十个孩子走过。警方更有可能抓到的是路过看到车里插着钥匙、处于醉酒、吸毒、缺钱或无聊状态的普通人，而不是那种老练的偷车贼。
Case in point. Turns out Mark and Asia weren't the only ones on their block snared by the bait car. The boyfriend of their neighbor Sarah, who had no criminal record, drove the car on Friday night around one in the morning. He drove down the block, turned it around, and parked it in the exact same spot. He was caught on video, laughing hysterically as he rolls down the block, with Willie Nelson's "On the Road Again" cranked up on the stereo. He was charged with a felony.
事实证明。结果马克和亚洲并不是街区里唯一被诱饵车辆诱捕的人。他们邻居萨拉的男友，没有犯罪记录，在周五凌晨一点左右开了这辆车。他沿着街区开了下去，掉头，停在完全相同的位置。他在视频里被拍到，当他开着车沿着街区滑行，音响里放着威利·纳尔逊的《再上路》时，发出歇斯底里的笑声。他被指控重罪。
After spending the day in jail, Mark and Asia are released, and right away they get a lawyer and start trying to get to the bottom of this whole mess. That's when they finally learn it's a bait car. That meant that when Mark called 911, the officer who answered the call went so far as to deceive him at his own home. He was furious.
在监狱里待了一天后，马克和亚洲被释放，他们立刻找了律师，开始试图弄清这一团糟。那时他们终于知道那是一辆诱饵车。这意味着当马克拨打911时，接电话的警察甚至欺骗了他，就在他自己的家门口。他非常愤怒。
And a lot of things ran through my head at that point. I was like, you know, even at best, they've just planted something to lure a criminal element 15 feet away from my bedroom window. You know?
在那一刻，我的脑海里闪过了很多念头。我想，你知道，最好的情况下，他们只是为了诱捕罪犯，把东西放在离我卧室窗户15英尺远的地方。你知道吗？
And then secondly, the conversation with the officer jumped to mind. I'm like, that cop knew exactly that that was a bait car, and sat there and lied to me that, oh, what's the problem, oh, you'd be surprised what we see around here, oh, these people don't register these cars, right? All of that was a lie, and they knew.
其次，警察的那段谈话浮现在脑海中。我想，那个警察明明知道那是辆诱饵车，却坐在那里对我撒谎，说“哦，有什么问题吗？哦，你在这里见怪不怪了，哦，这些人没有注册这些车，对吧？”所有这些都是谎言，他们心知肚明。
Yeah. I mean, how about the night you were detained? They didn't-- did that change the way you were thinking about their conversation when they said they had a tip, and someone had reported you at the car?
是啊。我是说，你被拘留的那天晚上呢？他们没有——当他们说他们得到举报，有人报了警说你们在车里时，那改变了你对他们谈话的看法吗？
Yeah. Which once again was a lie. I was pissed, yeah. I was pissed.
是的。那又是一个谎言。我很生气，是的。我很生气。
I repeatedly asked the police and prosecutors to explain their actions, but they refused to go on record. But Travis County attorney David Escamilla told a newspaper that nobody thinks Mark wanted to steal the car, but quote, "It's not appropriate to go out and jimmy the lock on the trunk of a car that doesn't belong to you."
我多次要求警察和检察官解释他们的行为，但他们拒绝公开表态。但特拉维斯县检察官戴维·埃斯卡米拉告诉报纸，没有人认为马克想偷这辆车，但引用，“没经过允许去撬开不属于你的车的后备箱是不合适的。”
Detective Spiller's affidavit also focuses on the fact that Mark tried to break into the trunk with a screwdriver, and even wore gloves like a real criminal. And there are couple important details Detective Spillers has left out of the affidavit. He doesn't mention that the car was parked in front of Mark's home, nor that Mark had called 911 as soon as he saw the car, or that Sarah had also called, or that there is surveillance video of Mark milling around, looking through papers in the glove compartment for 20 minutes.
斯皮勒斯侦探的宣誓书还集中在马克试图用螺丝刀撬开后备箱，甚至像真正的罪犯一样戴着手套这一点上。而斯皮勒斯侦探在宣誓书中漏掉了一些重要的细节。他没有提到车停在马克家门前，也没有提到马克一看到车就报了警，或者萨拉也报了警，或者有监控录像显示马克在车边徘徊，翻看手套箱里的文件达20分钟。
No. Instead, Detective Spillers concludes that he, quote, "believes this section constitutes more than mere curiosity or trying to locate the owner's information."
不。相反，斯皮勒斯侦探总结说，他引用，“相信这一行为不仅仅是出于好奇或试图找到车主的信息。”
The prosecutors were put in a tough spot with this one, given all the evidence of the couple's innocence. They almost immediately offered a deal. If Mark and Asia stayed out of trouble for a year, the prosecutors would completely drop the charges.
考虑到这对情侣无辜的所有证据，检察官们在这件事上陷入了困境。他们几乎立即提出了一个提议。如果马克和亚洲一年内不惹麻烦，检察官就完全撤销指控。
So we were going to take that offer, but then the other little small print of the offer was that you signed a guilty confession. And I refused to do that. I said no, and Mark did too. Both of us were like, we are not signing guilty confessions, because we didn't do this. And what we did do, we believe we were in the right for doing. So I mean, we're not signing a guilty confession.
所以我们打算接受那个提议，但提议的小字条款里写着你需要签署认罪书。我拒绝这样做。我说不，马克也拒绝了。我们俩都说，我们不会签署认罪书，因为我们没做过这件事。而我们所做的事情，我们相信我们是对的。所以，我的意思是，我们不会签署认罪书。
And I said no, you know? We'll just go ahead and go to trial. And I think if six of my peers here this story and apply any sort of level of common sense, no one's going to find me guilty of burglarizing a vehicle.
我说不，你知道吗？我们要继续进行审判。我想，如果我的六个同龄人听到这个故事并运用任何常识，没人会判定我犯有车辆盗窃罪。
So instead, Mark and Asia demand a jury trial. But like everything leading up to this point, it's not so simple. For more than a year and a half, they regularly show up for court ready for the trial, and for one reason or another, are repeatedly told it's being postponed. Finally, out of desperation, they decide to talk to the media-- me.
所以，马克和亚洲要求进行陪审团审判。但就像导致这一点的所有事情一样，事情并没有那么简单。一年半多的时间里，他们定期出庭准备审判，但因为各种原因，一再被告知推迟了。最后，出于绝望，他们决定联系媒体——我。
I wrote a story for the daily paper, the Austin American-Statesman, and the next week, prosecutors call with a much better offer. Asia's case would be dismissed outright, since she never technically entered the vehicle. Mark could plead no contest to criminal mischief, a class C misdemeanor, same as a traffic ticket. And if he stayed out of trouble for a month, the charge would be dismissed. He takes the deal.
我为日报《奥斯汀美国政治家报》写了一个报道，第二周，检察官打来电话，提出了一个好得多的提议。亚洲的案件直接撤销，因为她技术上从未进入车辆。马克可以对刑事破坏罪进行无抗辩，这是C级轻罪，和交通罚单一样。如果他一个月内不惹麻烦，指控就会被撤销。他接受了那个提议。
I don't know. There's a lot of things about the whole situation that just really piss me off, you know? And I try not to-- I try to keep it funny, because at times, I can get really angry about the situation.
我不知道。整个情况中有很多事情真的让我很火大，你知道吗？我尽量不——我尽量保持幽默，因为有时，我可能会对这种情况感到非常生气。
Mark and Asia paid a pretty high price. Asia wants to work with kids, and for the past two years, she couldn't even get a volunteer position because of the burglary charge on her record. It's cost them $3,000 for lawyers and to get their records expunged.
马克和亚洲付出了相当高的代价。亚洲想和孩子们一起工作，过去两年，因为她记录上的盗窃指控，她甚至连志愿者职位都得不到。这花了他们3000美元请律师并消除他们的记录。
But there are less tangible effects, as well. Asia works at a toy store, and a few months ago, someone left a cell phone on the floor. At first, Asia didn't touch it, just let it sit there, ringing and ringing and ringing. She was thinking, it's not mine. Could be a trap. Is it worth the risk? Eventually, she picked up the phone.
但也有一些不太明显的后果。亚洲在一家玩具店工作，几个月前，有人把一部手机掉在地板上。起初，亚洲没碰它，只是让它放在那里，不停地响。她在想，这不是我的。可能是个陷阱。值得冒险吗？最后，她接起了电话。
Michael May. When he's not chasing parked cars, he is books and culture editor at the Texas Observer.
迈克尔·梅。当他不追逐停放的车辆时，他是《德克萨斯观察家报》的书籍和文化编辑。
Coming up-- a message from Madonna on your home answering machine, and other really scary bait and switch techniques from people who feel they have no choice in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来——麦当娜在你家电话答录机上的留言，以及来自那些觉得别无选择的人的其他真正可怕的“诱饵与转换”技巧，一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- Bait and Switch.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的节目——“诱饵与转换”。
There was a flyer taped to the wall by the water fountain in the English department at Penn State this week. It says, "Raw," and then underneath it in bigger letters it says, "Sex," then underneath that, "Everything you need to know." And then under that, a website, rawsex.psu.org, and then under that, an address and time for a meeting of some sort. And then under that, at the very bottom, in teenie-weenie little type, you have to look very closely, it says, "Hosted by Orthodox Christian Fellowship, a ministry of Holy Trinity Orthodox Church."
本周宾夕法尼亚州立大学英语系的饮水机旁，墙上贴着一张传单。它写着“原始”，下面用更大的字写着“性”，下面写着“你需要知道的一切”。再下面是一个网站，rawsex.psu.org，下面是某种会议的地址和时间。然后，在最底部，用极小的字体，你必须仔细看，上面写着“由东正教基督徒团契主办，圣三一东正教会的一个事工”。
This flyer, yes, is a not-very-disguised bait and switch for Jesus. Which means us to the next act of our show, Act Two, Raw Sex, in which there will be no sex, but there will be a bunch of Jesus. One of our contributors, Dave Dickerson, was raised as an evangelical, and he says baiting and switching was just taken as a given. After all, being an evangelical comes with a huge responsibility to bring nonbelievers to God.
这张传单，是的，是一个伪装得并不怎么好的、耶稣的“诱饵与转换”。这把我们引向了节目的下一篇章，第二幕，原始性，在那里不会有性，但会有很多关于耶稣的内容。我们的撰稿人之一戴夫·迪克森是在福音派中长大的，他说“诱饵与转换”被认为是理所当然的。毕竟，作为福音派信徒，身上肩负着巨大的责任，要把非信徒带到上帝面前。
You have to. You know, Jesus actually said, go out into all the world and preach the gospel. And at the same time, we're also told, and they're going to hate you, just like they hated me. And so you have this kind of Biblical imperative to spread the word to people who don't want to hear it. And Paul at one point says, "Be as innocent as doves and as wise as serpents." And so, you know, a little bit of trickery to sort of like help the medicine go down seems like a reasonable thing to do.
你必须这样做。你知道，耶稣实际上说，走到世界各地去传福音。同时，我们也听到，他们会恨你，就像他们恨我一样。所以你有这种圣经的命令，要把福音传给那些不想听的人。保罗在某个地方说：“驯良像鸽子，灵巧像蛇。”所以，你知道，一点点小诡计来让药变得好喝点，似乎是一件合理的事情。
So what would you do?
那你当时会怎么做？
Well, when I was with Campus Crusade for Christ, who was famous for doing a lot of these things, one time we went out to California-- I was, you know, originally in Tucson. And we went up two people on the beach and said, hey, we're going to have like this luau party tonight! You know, come! We had flyers to hand out. And then it said, there's going to be music and food and drinks! It said "drinks." It didn't say "non-alcoholic" drinks. It just said "drinks."
好吧，当我在“校园基督十字军”时，他们以做很多这类事情而闻名，有一次我们去了加州——我，你知道，原来在图森。我们走向海滩上的两个人说，嘿，我们今晚要举办这个卢奥派对！你知道，快来！我们有传单要分发。上面写着，会有音乐、食物和饮料！它写着“饮料”。它没写“非酒精”饮料。它只是写了“饮料”。
And it was almost shameless. Because, of course, the women who would go out-- this was spring break-- they were in bikinis, and they were very attractive. And so we could see, they would go up to guys, and of course the guys would take the flyer. And they were going to go to this luau.
这简直是厚颜无耻。因为，当然，那些会出来的女性——那是春假——她们穿着比基尼，非常有吸引力。所以我们可以看到，她们会走向男人们，当然男人们会拿传单。他们会去参加这个卢奥。
And there was no real tip-off. It didn't say "Campus Crusade for Christ" at the bottom or anything like that. And when we actually had the actual presentation--
没有任何真正的预告。底部并没有写“校园基督十字军”什么的。当我们进行实际的演讲时——
Wait, the presentation, you mean the luau?
等等，演讲，你是说卢奥？
Yes. The "luau," in quotes, was kind of a skit show. You had the Diet Coke and whatever, and the pretzels. But the entertainment was, oh, you know, they would lip sync to Journey. There was an air guitar contrast. It was silly stuff that was wholesome and not at all like the wet T-shirt contest stuff they were maybe expecting.
是的，“卢奥”，用引号括起来，是一种短剧表演。你有健怡可乐什么的，还有椒盐卷饼。但娱乐活动是，哦，你知道，她们会假唱Journey的歌。有一个空气吉他比赛。这是一些很傻的东西，很健康，完全不像她们可能期待的湿T恤大赛那种东西。
And then every two or three episodes, someone would come out and say, you know, I just want to point out that Jesus Christ has made a huge difference in my life. And if you have any questions about that, you can talk to some people over here, and we've got literature, blah, blah, blah. And now back to your program.
然后每隔两三段，就会有人出来说，你知道，我只是想指出耶稣基督对我的生活产生了巨大的影响。如果你对此有任何问题，你可以和这边的一些人谈谈，我们有文献，巴拉巴拉什么的。现在回到你的节目。
And as this happened, after about the second or third of these sort of commercial interruptions, I could see-- I mean, I was cringing anyway. I knew this was wrong way to go. But you could see people looking at each other. Like, guys would go, oh. They would look around, and you could see them sort of thinking, these women are not on the market. You know, this is like the almost exact opposite of what we were promised!
而当这种情况发生时，在大约第二个或第三个这类商业插播之后，我能看到——我的意思是，我反正都在退缩。我知道这不是正确的做法。但你可以看到人们互相看着。就像，男人们会想，哦。他们会四处看看，你能看到他们那种想法，这些女性不是在寻找对象。你知道，这简直和我们被承诺的东西完全相反！
And so you would see this a lot. And you would always feel kind of strange about it.
所以你会经常看到这种情况。你总是会对此感到有点奇怪。
Right. I felt like there must be something kind of inherently flawed with the system. I got trained once in doing something-- and this is another classic-- to do a survey, a spiritual survey of people, to walk up and say, hey, we're doing a survey of religious attitudes. So do you believe in God? What sort of God do you believe in? And that kind of thing. And it would just ask a series of questions that would eventually lead them to, by the way, do you belong to a church? Hey, would you like to join ours? That kind of thing.
对。我觉得这个系统本身一定存在某种缺陷。我曾经接受过做某事的培训——这是另一个经典案例——去做一项调查，对人们进行精神调查，走到人们面前说，嘿，我们正在做一项关于宗教态度的调查。所以你相信上帝吗？你相信什么样的上帝？之类的事情。然后它只会问一系列问题，最终会引导他们到，顺便问一下，你属于某个教会吗？嘿，你想加入我们的教会吗？诸如此类。
And we got put into pairs. And this friend of mine and I started at one end of the campus. And while we were walking down this thing, I had all these ideas in my head, thinking, OK. What if they ask, like, who's sponsoring the survey? Or what statistical model are you using? You know, we were in college enough to know that there's a survey, and then there's a survey. And we hit a statistics major, we're in trouble.
我们被分成了两人一组。我和我的这个朋友在校园的一头开始。当我们沿着这条路走的时候，我脑子里全是这些想法，心想，好的。如果他们问，谁在赞助这项调查怎么办？或者你们用的是什么统计模型？你知道，我们上大学够久了，知道什么叫调查，什么是真正的调查。如果我们碰到一个统计学专业的学生，我们就麻烦了。
And one woman came by, and my friend said, I don't know. She looks kind of busy or angry, so let's avoid that. And this other guy came by, and he said, this doesn't seem right. And we kept talking each other out of confronting people. We're like halfway down the campus, and finally we just looked at each other and said, we just can't do this, can we?
一个女人走过来，我的朋友说，我不知道。她看起来有点忙或者生气，所以我们避开那个吧。另一个家伙走过来，他说，这看起来不对劲。我们一直在说服对方不要去面对人们。我们走到了校园的一半，最后我们只是看着对方说，我们就是做不到这一点，对吧？
But is the thing that bothered you the fact that you're going to have to walk up to strangers, or is the thing that bothered you that you were walking up to strangers under a false pretense?
但是让你烦恼的事情是你将不得不走近陌生人，还是你是在虚假的借口下走近陌生人？
Oh. Well, it was both. But clearly the false pretense was supposed to make it easier, was supposed to give us cover so that we didn't seem religious. And it wasn't fooling us. So it seemed both false and didn't really help.
哦。好吧，两者都有。但显然虚假的借口是为了让它更容易，是为了给我们掩护，这样我们看起来就不像宗教人士。而且它并没有愚弄我们。所以它看起来既虚假也没什么帮助。
There's a big debate among evangelicals about how to better reach out to non-believers. You'll find shelves of books on this at Christian bookstores. One of the evangelicals who's trying to change some of the old tactics is a guy named Jim Henderson. And he's tried all kinds of things to reach non-believers.
关于如何更好地接触非信徒，福音派内部存在着巨大的争论。你在基督教书店里会找到满架子关于这个的书。其中一位试图改变一些旧策略的福音派信徒是一个叫吉姆·亨德森的人。他尝试了各种方法来接触非信徒。
When a guy named Hement Mehta offered his own soul for sale on eBay to the highest bidder, it was Jim Henderson who won the auction with a $504 bid, which is, you know, cheap for a soul. And what he we did with that money was he simply asked Mehta to attend a few churches with him and tell them what was persuasive and what put him off. This project led to a book.
当一个叫赫曼特·梅塔的人在eBay上出价最高出售自己的灵魂时，是吉姆·亨德森以504美元赢得了拍卖，这可是，你知道，对于一个灵魂来说很便宜了。他用那些钱做的是，他只是要求梅塔和他一起去参加几次教会，告诉他们什么是有说服力的，什么是让人反感的。这个项目催生了一本书。
Henderson has another book called Evangelism Without Additives. He says in his decades as a pastor trying to convert people, he noticed that sinners like Jesus, but they don't like Jesus's people. Which led Henderson to completely rethink how he was approaching non-believers.
亨德森还有一本叫《无添加的传福音》的书。他说在他作为牧师试图转化人们的几十年里，他注意到罪人喜欢耶稣，但他们不喜欢耶稣的信徒。这促使亨德森完全重新思考他如何接近非信徒。
It was not an epiphany. It dawned on me slowly that I was tired of feeling bad. I was tired of thinking about you as a project instead of you as a person. And so I didn't like that.
这不是一个顿悟。我慢慢地意识到，我厌倦了感觉糟糕。我厌倦了把你当作一个项目，而不是把你当作一个人。所以我很不喜欢那样。
And then I also noticed that in spite of all the preaching I did about this to get other people to do it, they just wouldn't do it. I mean, they're just Christians, ordinary Christians, vote with their [UNINTELLIGIBLE], and they just do not participate in these programs.
然后我还注意到，尽管我为此做了所有的布道，让其他人去做这件事，但他们就是不做。我的意思是，他们只是基督徒，普通的基督徒，他们投票给他们的[听不清]，他们只是不参与这些项目。
In the programs to evangelize, you mean? They wouldn't evangelize?
你说的是传福音的项目吗？他们不会去传福音？
Yeah. I mean, you can push them for a few days like a diet or something like that, and then it's like, are we done with this now? Can we go back to our normal life of thinking about ourselves? So--
是啊。我的意思是，你可以像节食之类的强迫他们几天，然后就好像，我们这次结束了吗？我们可以回到我们只想着自己的正常生活吗？所以——
Usually it doesn't work.
通常这不起作用。
No, it doesn't work. It doesn't work for the same reasons it doesn't work for normal humans. We don't like being pitched. We don't like being treated that way. I don't like being invited to a party to kibbitz and chat, and then find out you have a pitch you want to give me. You know, we can smell a sell coming.
不，它不起作用。它不起作用的原因和它对普通人不起作用的原因一样。我们不喜欢被强推。我们不喜欢被那样对待。我不喜欢被邀请去参加一个聚会聊天，然后发现你有一个想要强加给我的推销。你知道，我们能闻到推销的味道。
And by the way, most of the ways you have observed evangelism being done as it's being marketed are ineffective. The large rallies-- all that stuff. The statistics are just abysmal about the number of converts that actually stick. It does not result in what the church wants.
顺便说一句，你观察到的绝大多数被营销的传福音方式都是无效的。大型集会——所有那些东西。关于实际留下的皈依者人数的统计数据简直惨不忍睹。它并没有达到教会想要的结果。
The church wants disciples. Jesus actually didn't say, go out and make converts. He said, go make disciples. Which is a completely different project.
教会想要门徒。耶稣其实并没有说，出去制造皈依者。他说，去制造门徒。这是一个完全不同的项目。
So the founder of our movement, Jesus, did not model this behavior. You never had to lower himself to a bait and switch.
所以我们运动的创始人耶稣并没有模仿这种行为。你从不需要降低自己去使用“诱饵与转换”。
So this has been an adoption of sort of American consumerism that we've adopted as a church. And it's really largely based on sales. The way of getting people to join.
所以这已经成为了一种美国消费主义的接纳，我们作为教会接纳了它。它在很大程度上实际上是基于销售的。获取人们加入的方式。
I mean, quite frankly, I want people to follow Jesus. I believe Jesus is God and all that stuff. But I am completely done with the whole evangelism as a sales model deal. I'm done with it.
我的意思是，坦率地说，我希望人们跟随耶稣。我相信耶稣是上帝等等。但我完全受够了整个以销售模式进行传福音的事情。我受够了。
So walk me through what is that you're advocating. You have this thing called doable evangelism. Evangelism that actually normal people can do without feeling weird about it. So give me the steps of it. Like what do I do if I want to do it?
所以带我看看你在倡导什么。你有这个叫“可行性传福音”的东西。普通的传福音，人们不用感到奇怪就能做。所以给我具体的步骤。如果我想做，我该怎么做？
Doable evangelism does not concern itself with converting people. It's not about sales. It's about connecting. So the paradigm is about connecting with people.
“可行性传福音”不关心转化人们。这不是关于销售。这是关于连接。所以这个范式是关于与人们连接。
The way we connect, there's three what we call spiritual practices for connecting with people. Number one, notice people. Practice the art of noticing. Sit and watch. Sit in the mall and watch people go by and ask yourself, I wonder what's going on with that person. Just reflect.
我们连接的方式，有三种所谓的与人们连接的精神实践。第一，注意人们。练习注意的艺术。坐着观察。坐在商场里观察人们走过，问自己，我想知道那个人发生了什么。只是反思。
The second one is, pray for people behind their backs. You know, Christians like to pray for people. And we believe prayer matters. So pray for them behind their backs. Unauthorized prayers. You don't need their permission. You can pray. But pray for these people. It's fine. It's not going to hurt them. It's not going to hurt you. Maybe something good will happen. Who knows.
第二个是，在背后为人们祈祷。你知道，基督徒喜欢为人们祈祷。我们相信祈祷很重要。所以要在背后为他们祈祷。未经授权的祈祷。你不需要他们的许可。你可以祈祷。但要为这些人祈祷。没关系。这不会伤害他们。这不会伤害你。也许会发生好事。谁知道呢。
The third thing is to go to someone and actually listen. And the way you listen, usually you say something like, how are you? And then you listen. And the person will be amazed when you don't interrupt them with your own story of how you are not doing yourself.
第三件事是走到某人面前真正地倾听。你倾听的方式，通常你会说类似“你好吗？”的话。然后你倾听。当你不打断他们，讲述你自己怎么怎么不好的故事时，那个人会感到惊讶。
So you would send people out. You say, I want you to listen to people, I want you to notice people. And then does this work in bringing people to Jesus? Or is that just like the first step?
所以你会派人出去。你说，我要你们倾听人们，我要你们注意人们。然后这在把人们带到耶稣面前方面有效吗？还是那只是第一步？
So that's a question, of course, Christians ask us. They want to know about numbers and results.
所以这是一个问题，当然，基督徒会问我们。他们想知道数字和结果。
But I feel like that's a fair question. Because you're saying, like, well, this is a kind of doable evangelism. So all right. I can go out and listen to people. That part I can do. So where's the part where they come to Jesus?
但我感觉那是个公平的问题。因为你在说，好吧，这是一种可行性的传福音。所以好吧。我可以出去倾听人们。那部分我可以做。那么他们归向耶稣的部分在哪儿？
You have to keep in mind, our mission, our goal is to not to get converts. Our goal is to get Christians out connecting with non-Christians. Our goal is to get Christians learning how not to be jerks. Our goal is to help Christians learn to be normal.
你必须记住，我们的使命，我们的目标不是去获取皈依者。我们的目标是让基督徒出去与非基督徒连接。我们的目标是让基督徒学习如何不成为混蛋。我们的目标是帮助基督徒学习变得正常。
And what happens, over a period of time, is they start befriending people, and they get in people's social circles, and yes. Naturally, just like if you were interested in something and I knew you from some length of time, the likelihood of me going to the school you're recommending, buying the car you recommended increases, because we're in proximity to each other.
随之而来的是，过了一段时间，他们开始与人们成为朋友，他们进入了人们的社交圈，是的。自然地，就像如果你对某事感兴趣，而我认识你一段时间了，我去你推荐的学校、买你推荐的车，可能性就会增加，因为我们彼此靠近。
The way it happens is just through relationships. That's how human beings actually change, when you and I like each other. My saying is, when people like each other, the rules change.
这种情况发生的方式就是通过人际关系。这就是人类真正改变的方式，当我们彼此喜欢的时候。我的格言是，当人们彼此喜欢时，规则就会改变。
Is it possible that your tactic just leads to nothing? Like I think about my own circle of friends. And for whatever reasons now, I have a bunch of friends, my wife and I have a bunch of friends, who are very devout religious people. And we hang out with them, and we share our lives with them, but they are no influence at all in pulling us towards Christianity away from our staunch atheism, and vice versa.
有没有可能你的策略只是导致了什么都没有？比如我想想我自己的朋友圈。不管出于什么原因，现在我有很多朋友，我和我的妻子有很多朋友，他们是非常虔诚的宗教人士。我们和他们交往，我们和他们分享我们的生活，但他们在把我们推向基督教、远离我们坚定无神论这一点上根本没有任何影响，反之亦然。
That would be what my ideological enemies within evangelicalism would accuse me of. That this will lead to nothing. And so the alternative is for me, then, to imagine your social circle. What are your alternatives, then? To begin to intentionally try and persuade each other. You know, I have this one chance to try and get Ira Glass saved, so here I go.
那正是福音派内部我的意识形态敌人们会指责我的地方。这会导致什么都没有。所以对我来说，另一种选择就是去想象你的社交圈。那么你的选择是什么？开始有意地试图说服彼此。你知道，我有这次机会去尝试拯救艾拉·格拉斯，所以我就来了。
And then what happens as a result of that, typically, is that's the end of our relationship, and we go our separate ways. And so now I have zero influence in your life, and I'm not going to be able to be influenced by you, as well.
然后，通常发生的结果是，那是我们关系的终点，我们各奔东西。所以我对你的生活没有产生任何影响，我也没法被你影响。
When you describe it-- and I'm not saying this to be critical, I'm just observing-- what you're replacing bait and switch with is-- it's all bait. And then there's no switch at all! Honestly, you're just assuming that at some point, like, something will happen, and maybe it'll be good. And hopefully it'll be good.  Right? Because the bait was pretty good. And so let's just go with that.
当你描述它的时候——我这么说不是为了批评，我只是在观察——你用什么代替了“诱饵与转换”……这全都是诱饵。然后根本就没有转换！老实说，你只是假设在某个时刻，就像，会发生什么，也许它会是好的。希望它是好的。对吧？因为诱饵相当不错。所以我们就跟着那个走吧。
Now, that doesn't offend me in the least. I kind of like that. All bait, no switch. I might use that.
现在，那一点也没冒犯我。我有点喜欢那个。全是诱饵，没有转换。我可能会用那个说法。
I admit, I could be wrong, maybe I'm living a delusion, whatever, but this is one that I prefer over the alternatives. And I'm happy with that. Again, our goal is to get Christians engaged in the process. We're not concerned about results.
我承认，我可能是错的，也许我生活在幻觉中，随便吧，但这是我比其他替代选择更倾向的一种。我对那很满意。再说一次，我们的目标是让基督徒参与到这个过程中。我们不关心结果。
The average amount of time it takes to be a Christian, before you actually make a decision, is about four years. So I'm much more concerned about the starting like of faith. Why don't we try and get them across the starting line instead of the finish line?
一个人在真正做出决定之前，成为基督徒所需的平均时间大约是四年。所以我更关心信仰的起跑线。为什么我们不试着让他们跨越起跑线，而不是终点线呢？
Jim Henderson. He records his thoughts in books and at two websites, offthemap.com and doableevangelism.com.
吉姆·亨德森。他把他的想法记录在书中，以及两个网站，offthemap.com和doableevangelism.com。
Dave Dickerson, who we heard before him, has a book of his own called House of Cards : Love, Faith, and Other Social Expressions.
在他之前我们听到的戴夫·迪克森，有一本他自己的书叫《纸牌屋：爱、信仰和其他社会表达》。
Act Three. Friends With Economic Benefits.
第三幕。有经济利益的朋友。
People enter friendships with all kinds of agendas because, as Jim Henderson puts it, when people like each other, the rules change. Anna Boiko-Weyrauch has this story from the city of Accra in Ghana. She's changed the name of the woman that she interviews in this story.
人们带着各种各样的议程进入友谊，因为正如吉姆·亨德森所说，当人们彼此喜欢时，规则就会改变。安娜·博伊科-维劳赫在加纳的阿克拉带来了这个故事。她更改了她在这个故事中采访的那个女人的名字。
It was Saturday night, and I was walking around alone in the city, and I stopped at the shop to get some water. People were hanging out on benches in front, eating dinner, playing with a little girl. A woman in a yellow dress called out to me, "Hey Obruni," white lady, "what do you want?"
那天是周六晚上，我独自在城里走着，我在一家商店停下来买水。人们坐在前面的长椅上闲逛，吃着晚餐，和一个小女孩玩耍。一个穿着黄色裙子的女人对我喊道：“嘿，奥布鲁尼”（白人女士），“你想要什么？”
That's how I met Marion. I liked her right away. She seemed genuine, direct. We ended up spending the rest of the evening sitting on the wooden bench together, eating beans and rice and talking. Her husband was in Italy, and my boyfriend was in the U.S., so we bonded over that. She said she would be my friend, and I really needed one. And she warned me. She told me I should be more careful around Ghanaians, that they would try to cheat me.
那就是我遇到马里昂的方式。我立刻就喜欢上了她。她看起来真诚、直接。我们最后在木凳上坐了一整个晚上，吃着豆子和米饭聊天。她的丈夫在意大利，我的男友在美国，所以我们因此有了共同语言。她说她会做我的朋友，而我确实需要一个朋友。而且她警告了我。她告诉我，我对加纳人应该更小心，他们会试图欺骗我。
Now, this isn't the first time I'd heard about Ghanaians scamming foreigners. Who doesn't get those fake e-mails from West Africa? But here in Ghana, they call it "sakawa," which some say comes from a word in the Hausa language that means to put something into something else. Like, I put the stolen credit card number into the order form. Or more metaphorically, I scammed those people so well, I've got them in my pocket.
现在，这不是我第一次听说加纳人诈骗外国人。谁没收到过那些来自西非的假电子邮件？但在加纳，他们称之为“萨卡瓦”（sakawa），有些人说这个词来自豪萨语，意思是把某样东西放进另一样东西里。比如，我把偷来的信用卡号放进订单表。或者更隐喻地说，我把那些人诈骗得太好了，我把他们抓在手心里了。
A lot of sakawa scams start on internet dating sites. The scammers are usually young men. They're known as sakawa boys. They pretend to be women online, and start chatting with guys overseas, hoping to hook one of them in a relationship. Marion told me her friends and cousins do this all the time.
很多萨卡瓦诈骗始于网上约会网站。骗子通常是年轻人。他们被称为萨卡瓦男孩。他们在网上假扮女性，开始和海外的男人们聊天，希望能把他们钩进一段关系中。马里昂告诉我，她的朋友和堂表亲总是这样做。
When we were talking on the bench, she leaned in closer, and she told me in a low voice that she was right in the middle of a sakawa scam. She was the bait.
当我们在长椅上聊天时，她凑近了一些，用低沉的声音告诉我，她正处于一个萨卡瓦骗局之中。她是诱饵。
Her friends and cousins, sakawa boys, had asked her to talk to a foreigner they were scamming. They wanted her to talk to him on the phone and pretend to be the girl he'd been chatting with online. I asked if I could interview her about it, so later we sat down and talked.
她的朋友和堂表亲，萨卡瓦男孩，要求她和他们正在诈骗的一个外国人聊天。他们想让她在电话里和他说话，假装成他一直在网上聊天的女孩。我问我能不能就这件事采访她，所以后来我们坐下来聊了聊。
So the first time they asked you, your cousins, what did they ask you?
所以你堂表亲第一次要求你时，他们要求你做什么？
OK.  They told me to tell the man, my parents are dead. That no one looks after me. So I spoke to the man. I told him, yeah, it's true. My parents are dead. No one looks after me. So I needed money to start something. He said, oh, no problem. The white man said, no problem.
好的。他们告诉我告诉那个男人，我的父母去世了。没人照顾我。所以我确实和那个男人说了。我告诉他，是的，是真的。我的父母去世了。没人照顾我。所以我需要钱来开始做些什么。他说，哦，没问题。那个白人男人说，没问题。
Marion played an important role in the scam, but according to her, she wasn't on the inside. She was the bait, not an official partner. So not entitled to a cut of the money. Instead, it was more like she was helping her cousin out so he would be more inclined to return the favor later, and give her money when she asked him for it. But only however much he chose to give her.
马里昂在骗局中扮演了一个重要角色，但据她说，她并不是核心人物。她是诱饵，而不是正式合伙人。所以没资格分钱。相反，这更像是她在帮她堂表亲的忙，这样他以后就更愿意回报她，在她向他要钱时给她钱。但只能是他选择给她的那么多。
So how much money did your cousin receive from this man?
那你堂表亲从那个人那里收到了多少钱？
Thousands of dollars. He gets money. So much. My cousin, he's not the only person. There are many who collect money from the whites, who spend the whites' money.
数千美元。他拿到钱。非常多。我的堂表亲，他不是唯一的人。有很多人从白人那里收集钱，消费白人的钱。
Marion's cousins recruited her to talk to a man she called Mr. Johnson from New York.
马里昂的堂表亲招募她去和一个她称为纽约约翰逊先生的人说话。
We chat, OK. Sometimes we talk about love. Because he is in love. So we talk about love, sex. Having sex on the phone. I make him feel good about me so that when I need anything, he can send me.
我们聊天，好的。有时我们谈论爱。因为他恋爱了。所以我们谈论爱，性。在电话里做爱。我让他对我感觉良好，这样当我需要任何东西时，他能给我发过来。
And how long do you talk on the phone?
你们在电话里聊多久？
More than four hours. We talk, we talk. We talk, sometimes midnight he calls me. We chat, we chat. He makes me laugh. Sometimes he entertains me. We're jovial. We joke, and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. But Mr. Jones could be my grandfather.
四个多小时。我们聊，我们聊。我们谈，有时半夜他给我打电话。我们聊，我们聊。他让我笑。有时他娱乐我。我们很愉快。我们开玩笑，和[听不清]。但琼斯先生可能是我祖父的年纪了。
He's very old.
他非常老。
Yes. About 72 years. He's old. But when he talks, he's bold. He talks to me. We talk about love. But I pity him. Because he sends my cousin money so much.
是的。大约72岁。他老了。但他说话时很大胆。他和我聊天。我们谈论爱。但我同情他。因为他给我堂表亲寄了那么多钱。
Marion says that after two conversations with Mr. Johnson, she couldn't stand the deception anymore, and she told him the truth-- that he was being conned. She said she told him not to send any more money. She says that he thanked her, and that her cousins don't know she's the one who busted up their scam.
马里昂说，在和约翰逊先生谈了两次话后，她再也无法忍受这种欺骗，她告诉了他真相——他被骗了。她说她告诉他不要再寄钱了。她说他感谢了她，而她的堂表亲们不知道是她破坏了他们的骗局。
But I couldn't verify anything she was telling me. I asked her for Mr. Johnson's phone number, but she didn't get it from her cousin's phone for me, even though she swore she would. And I couldn't talk to her cousins without getting her in trouble.
但我无法核实她告诉我的任何事情。我向她要约翰逊先生的电话号码，但她没有从她堂表亲的手机里为我拿到号码，尽管她发誓她会。而且如果我不让她陷入麻烦，我就无法和她的堂表亲谈。
And somehow, during the interview, the more we talked about the scam, the more confused I got. The details kept getting murkier. First she said she only helped scam Mr. Johnson, then she mentioned others. And the timeline of what happened with Mr. Johnson became less and less clear. At one point, she said she hadn't talked to Mr. Johnson or seen any of her sakawa friends since she got married.
而且不知何故，在采访过程中，我们越谈论这个骗局，我就越困惑。细节变得越来越模糊。起初她说她只帮着诈骗了约翰逊先生，然后她又提到了其他人。约翰逊先生事件发生的时间线变得越来越不清晰。有一次，她说她自从结婚以来就没和约翰逊先生聊过，也没见过她那些萨卡瓦朋友。
So this was all before you became married?
所以这一切都是在你结婚之前发生的？
Yes. Since I got married.
是的。自从我结婚以来。
And so you've been married since--
所以你从——结婚以来。
2007.
2007年。
But you were speaking to Mr. Johnson even this year.
但你甚至今年还在和约翰逊先生说话。
I said that because when we first met, she said she was talking to Mr. Johnson then. That was only a few months ago. When I reminded her, Marion said--
我那么说是为了——当我们第一次见面时，她说她那时在和约翰逊先生聊天。那才几个月前。当我提醒她时，马里昂说——
No. This year, let me see. No, I don't actually remember. I don't remember.
不。今年，让我想想。不，我其实不记得了。我不记得了。
And then the interview took a different turn. She hinted I should give her money. She needed a job, she said, and she had a lot of stories to tell. She told me she was broke, which I wasn't sure I believed. There are a lot of poor people in Ghana, but Marion doesn't seem to be one of them. Her mom owns a hair salon and a grocery store. Her husband has a new TV and kitchen appliances. But she said her mom is sick of giving her money on the time, and her husband ran into immigration problems in Italy.
然后采访有了不同的转折。她暗示我应该给她钱。她说她需要一份工作，她有很多故事要讲。她告诉我她破产了，我不确定我是否相信。加纳有很多穷人，但马里昂似乎不是其中之一。她妈妈有一家美发沙龙和一家杂货店。她丈夫有一台新电视和厨房电器。但她说她妈妈对总是给她钱感到厌倦了，她丈夫在意大利遇到了移民问题。
We went back and forth a while, and it kept coming down to the same thing. She said she wants foreigners to give her money like they give the sakawa boys, but she doesn't want to defraud anyone.
我们来回谈了一段时间，最后总是归结为同样的事情。她说她想让外国人给她钱，就像他们给萨卡瓦男孩一样，但她不想诈骗任何人。
Yeah, I want the same thing, but I don't want it in a fraud way. I wouldn't lie to them, men, stealing from them. Because what they are doing is stealing. I can't do that.
是的，我想要同样的东西，但我不想以诈骗的方式。我不会对他们撒谎，男人，从他们那里偷窃。因为他们正在做的是偷窃。我做不到那样。
One thing is, I don't lie. Even if I would lie, not because the way you approach to me, you are like a sister, you see? That's why I don't want to lie to you. That's why I told you everything. I don't want to lie to you. I'm telling the true facts.
有一件事是，我不撒谎。即使我会撒谎，也不是因为你接近我的方式，你就像个姐妹，你明白吗？这就是为什么我不想对你撒谎。这就是为什么我告诉了你一切。我不想对你撒谎。我说的是真实的事实。
Sakawa is about setting up a basic transaction. You find what the other person wants, like a girlfriend, a radio story, and you use it as bait. I believe Marion did see me as a friend, but also as an opportunity. Frankly, that's how I saw her too.
萨卡瓦是关于建立一个基本的交易。你发现另一个人想要什么，比如一个女朋友、一个广播故事，你把它当作诱饵。我相信马里昂确实把我当成了朋友，但也当成了一个机会。坦率地说，我也是那样看她的。
We hung out a couple of times as friends beside the interview. We ate lunch-- some spicy Ghanaian food-- and played with her cute little baby. A few days later, I called her to press for Mr. Johnson's phone number, but as soon as we decided talking, she yelled that I was only interested in her as a story. I wasn't interested in being a real friend. Then she hung up on me. In her version of the story, I'm the opportunist.
除了采访之外，我们作为朋友出去过几次。我们吃了午饭——一些辛辣的加纳食物——并和她可爱的婴儿玩耍。几天后，我打电话给她坚持要约翰逊先生的电话号码，但我们刚决定谈话，她就大喊说我只对她作为一个故事感兴趣。我根本没兴趣成为一个真正的朋友。然后她挂断了我的电话。在她版本的那个故事里，我是那个投机者。
Anna Boiko-Weyrauch reports for Voice of America and other radio programs from Ghana.
安娜·博伊科-维劳赫从加纳为美国之音和其他广播节目报道。
Act Four. Cherry and Me.
第四幕。樱桃和我。
Before we get to the bait and switches that have entered the life of Bill Cotter, some background. He used to do a nice businesses restoring very old books-- usually over 300 years old-- and decided a few years back to start dealing rare books as well. To finance this business, as he's written, he accepted a few of the roughly 500,000 low-interest credit card offers that come in the mail every day. Which worked, for a while. His business grew until a book deal that he had went very, very bad. Cost him $15,000. And all his credit cards, one by one, slipped into delinquency.
在我们谈到进入比尔·科特生活的“诱饵与转换”之前，先来点背景。他曾经做过修复非常古老的书籍——通常超过300年历史——的不错业务，几年前决定开始经营珍本图书。为了资助这项业务，正如他所写，他接受了一些每天寄到信箱里的大约50万份低息信用卡申请。这在一段时间内确实有效。他的业务一直在增长，直到他达成的一笔书单出了非常非常大的问题。让他损失了1.5万美元。而他所有的信用卡，一个接一个地陷入了拖欠。
He felt terrible, naturally. Guilty, ashamed. And this is where we'll pick up our story.
他自然感到很糟糕。内疚、羞耻。这就是我们要从哪里拾起我们的故事。
February 14, 2008. Annie, my girlfriend of ten years, comes in the house and says in a tone not entirely free of suspicion, "Look who got a valentine." She holds a pink, squarish envelope hand-addressed to me just out of my reach. "I see your secret admirer was too modest include a return address," Annie says. My secret admirer was also too modest to use a stamp. The envelope had been posted by bulk rate meter. "So what's her name?" Annie says. I open it. "Friendly Card Services," I say.
2008年2月14日。安妮，我十年的女友，走进屋子，用一种并不完全没有怀疑的语气说：“看谁收到了情人节卡片。”她拿着一个粉红色的、方形的、手写着我名字的信封，让我够不着。“我看出你的秘密崇拜者太谦虚了，没写回信地址，”安妮说。我的秘密崇拜者也太谦虚了，没用邮票。信封是通过大宗汇率计费邮寄的。“那她叫什么名字？”安妮说。我打开它。“友好卡服务公司，”我说。
"Dear Mr. Cotter, Your account is currently four months past due. Please pay $19,243.53 immediately, or we will be forced to deliver your account to a third party for more aggressive collection efforts. Sincerely, Friendly Customer Appreciation Department."
“亲爱的科特先生，您的账户目前已逾期四个月。请立即支付19243.53美元，否则我们将被迫将您的账户移交给第三方进行更积极的催收工作。真诚的，友好客户感恩部。”
I have long since stopped entering calls from the many, many collectors coming after my many, many wholly unmeetable obligations. These calls, which routinely number 200 every day, start exactly at eight in the morning, and they end exactly at nine o'clock at night.
我早就停止接听许多许多正在追踪我许多许多完全无法满足的债务的催收员的电话了。这些电话每天通常有200个，正好在早上八点开始，晚上九点结束。
In the beginning, identifying a collector was easy. The area codes were almost always something numerologically unclean combination of sixes and eights. Then one day I get a call from my own area code. I listen to the message.
起初，识别催收员很容易。区号几乎总是数字命理学上不洁的六和八的组合。然后有一天，我接到了自己区号的电话。我听了留言。
"Yo, hey, Bill. This is Cherry. What's up? I haven't heard from you for ages."
“哟，嘿，比尔。我是樱桃。怎么了？好久没你的消息了。”
Whoa. Do I know a Cherry? I Google the number. My old friend Cherry apparently lives at the I Love America Financial Recovery Resolution and Outstanding Account Consolidation and Settlementations Response Center, LLC, with offices in Los Angeles and Guckeen, Minnesota.
哇。我认识樱桃吗？我用谷歌搜索了这个号码。我的老朋友樱桃显然住在“我爱美国金融恢复决议与未偿账户合并与结算回应中心有限责任公司”，在洛杉矶和明尼苏达州的古肯设有办事处。
Variants on this gambit abound. Citibank sometimes sends their threats express mail. Such letters usually start, "Dear debtor, you're probably wondering why we just paid to overnight you just one sheet of paper." I always do wonder, but they never explain. They simply go on to itemize the ways in which you've disappointed them, and conclude with a demand for payment in full, just like their not overnighted letters. Other lenders disguise their collection notices inside and out as surprisingly convincing U.S. treasury checks. Discover's method is to simply send one letter a day.
这种策略的变体层出不穷。花旗银行有时会发加急邮件威胁。此类信件通常开头是，“亲爱的债务人，你可能在想为什么我们刚才付钱给你快递这一张纸。”我总是想知道，但他们从不解释。他们只是继续逐项列出你如何让他们失望的方式，最后以要求全额付款结束，就像他们非快递的信件一样。其他贷款机构将他们的催收通知伪装成出奇令人信服的美国国库支票。发现卡的方法只是每天寄一封信。
April 25, 2008. My bankruptcy attorney, Mr. H., during our first meeting, charges me with many tasks, the most demanding and subjective of which is evaluating my assets. For most objects, there are guidelines. Clothes-- 10% of retail. Cars-- Blue Book value. Buffalo nickel collection-- whatever you can get on eBay.
2008年4月25日。我的破产律师H先生，在我们第一次会面时，给了我许多任务，其中最苛刻和主观的就是评估我的资产。对于大多数物体，有指导方针。衣服——零售价的10%。汽车——蓝皮书价值。水牛镍币收藏——你在eBay上能得到的任何价格。
But occasionally an object occurs whose worth is subjective. We acquired our housecat in the fall of '04. In all respects, he underperforms as a pet. He won't pounce or chase a laser dot. On every page of his vet file are big fluorescent stickers that say, "Will Bite." He's taught himself to frown. So under "Animals" on page 14 of the Bankruptcy Questionnaire, I generously evaluate him at $0.50.
但偶尔会出现价值主观的物体。我们在04年秋天领养了我们的家猫。在各方面，他作为宠物表现都不佳。他不会猛扑或追逐激光点。在他兽医文件的每一页上都有巨大的荧光贴纸，上面写着“会咬人”。他学会了皱眉。所以，在破产问卷第14页的“动物”栏下，我大方地评估他为0.50美元。
"What's a Vinnie?" asks Mr. H. "A cat," I say. "That cat?" "Yes, sir," I say. "$10," he says, and then wipes out my figure and enters his own.
“什么是文尼？”H先生问。“一只猫，”我说。“那只猫？”“是的，先生，”我说。“10美元，”他说，然后划掉了我的数字，填入了他自己的。
This is frustrating, because the job of a bankruptcy attorney is to assign as small a value as possible to each of my objects. "How about $3?" I suggest. "Why don't you just give the beast away, then?" he asks. "Just drop it off behind a chicken restaurant." I look at him, trying to decide what to say. If you can't bare a shameful truth to your attorney, then to whom?
这很令人沮丧，因为破产律师的工作是为我的每一个物体赋予尽可能小的价值。“3美元怎么样？”我建议。“那你为什么不把这野兽送人呢？”他问。“直接把它丢在炸鸡店后面。”我看着他，试图决定说什么。如果你不能向你的律师揭露一个可耻的真相，那还能向谁揭露呢？
"Well," I admit, "I like him."
“嗯，”我承认，“我喜欢他。”
"$10, then. Next item."
“那就10美元。下一项。”
September 28, 2008. Bait and switching now starts in earnest. A neighbor leaves a Post-it note on my door saying she's just gotten a call from someone trying to find me, that the caller said it was an emergency, and to have me call this 866 number immediately. My parents, sisters, and former employees call me. "Billy, some angry dude who will not identify himself or his business is looking for you."
2008年9月28日。“诱饵与转换”现在正式开始。一个邻居在我的门上留了一张便利贴，说她刚接到一个试图找我的人的电话，打电话的人说这是紧急情况，让我立刻拨打这个866号码。我的父母、姐妹和前员工打电话给我。“比利，有个愤怒的家伙不肯透露他的姓名或业务，正在找你。”
The subterfuge isn't just from collectors. Envelopes arrive with absolutely no markings at all, demanding to be opened. These contain letters from law firms offering to defend me. Similar envelopes arrive from debt consolidation companies posing as law firms offering to defend me.
诡计不仅仅来自催收员。信封没有任何标记就寄到了，要求打开。里面装的是律师事务所提供的辩护信。类似的信封来自冒充律师事务所提供辩护的债务合并公司。
Somehow mailed threats aren't that worrisome. Not like calls. Like a voicemail I received dialed from a spooky telephone number made of nothing but zeros, and consisting only of the Madonna song "Open Your Heart" played in its entirety. Among the lyrics is this provocative passage.
不知何故，邮寄的威胁并不那么令人担忧。不像电话。就像我收到的一条语音留言，从一个由全零组成的诡异电话号码拨出，内容只是完整播放的麦当娜歌曲《打开你的心》。歌词中有一段挑衅性的段落。
[MUSIC - "OPEN YOUR HEART" BY MADONNA]
[音乐 - 麦当娜的《打开你的心》]
I follow you around but you can't see/ You're too wrapped up in yourself to notice/ So you choose to look the other way/ Well, I've got something to say/ Don't try to run, I can keep up with you...
我跟着你到处走，但你看不见/你太专注于自己而没注意到/所以你选择看另一个方向/好吧，我有话要说/不要试图跑，我可以跟上你……
[MUSIC FADES]
[音乐淡出]
October 10, 2008. By now, I've learned not only to never answer the telephone, but also to ignore knocks at the door. But one afternoon, I'm expecting an interesting rare book restoration job to be delivered by UPS. I checked the tracking number, which indicated that my package was On Vehicle For Delivery. Hark! The downshift of a grumpy diesel engine. I peek out the blinds. There, parked under a beautiful, spreading pecan tree, my beautiful, brown delivery truck. Hark again! A firm, authority-backed rap.
2008年10月10日。到目前为止，我已经学会了不仅永远不要接电话，还要无视敲门声。但一天下午，我正期待着一笔有趣的珍本图书修复工作由UPS运送过来。我检查了追踪号码，它显示我的包裹“正在派送车辆上”。听！那是吵闹的柴油发动机减速的声音。我从百叶窗偷看。那里，停在一棵美丽的、舒展开来的山核桃树下，是我那辆漂亮、棕色的快递车。再次听！那是坚定、带有权威感的敲门声。
I answer. Standing before me is a diminutive woman wearing not a penny-brown UPS uniform, but a tan polo shirt and khakis. Just as I was about say, "Hey, what's with the merry new uniform?" and "Where's my parcel?" I see the UPS truck driving away. I notice a pistol at her waste.
我应门了。站在我面前的是一个身材娇小的女人，穿着的不是那种便士棕色的UPS制服，而是一件棕褐色马球衫和卡其裤。就在我正要说，“嘿，这身欢快的制服是怎么回事？”和“我的包裹在哪儿？”时，我看到UPS车开走了。我注意到她腰间有一把手枪。
She announces that she's from the Travis County Constable's Office, precinct five, and that she's here to deliver a citation initiated by Citibank South Dakota N.A. She hands me a sheaf of papers. I have been officially sued.
她宣布她是来自特拉维斯县治安官办公室，五区，她来递交一份由南达科他州花旗银行发起的传票。她递给我一叠文件。我正式被起诉了。
Annie, my girlfriend, in her customarily disarming fashion, invites the deputy inside for a cup of coffee. Annie asks the deputy if she would like cream and sugar. The deputy begins to cry.
安妮，我的女友，以她习惯性的卸下防备的方式，邀请副警长进去喝杯咖啡。安妮问副警长是否要加奶油和糖。副警长开始哭泣。
Annie sits her down on the couch. We listen as Dana Perry, the deputy, confesses how much she hates her hypocritical job. She's in some pretty bad debt herself. And how all she really wants to do is go back to school and play with her baby and start an organic lavender farm. Annie gives her to-go coffee and some rubber tawdries left over from a cashed pinata to give to the baby. And, just in case, Mr. H.'s business card.
安妮让她坐在沙发上。我们听着副警长达娜·佩里忏悔她是多么讨厌她虚伪的工作。她自己也背负着相当沉重的债务。她真正想做的只是回到学校，和她的孩子一起玩，开一个有机薰衣草农场。安妮给了她外带咖啡和一些从打碎的皮纳塔里剩下的橡胶玩偶给她的孩子。而且，以防万一，还有H先生的名片。
October 22, 2009. Finally, case number 091263-CAG, my bankruptcy, is officially filed. My creditors will get $4,911 worth of rare book inventory, $750 worth of archival letter and paper, and $40.45 in cash. I don't have enough rare book inventory left to start fresh as a bookseller, but luckily, I do still have restoration tools and materials, so bookbinding is the direction I'll go.
2009年10月22日。最终，091263-CAG案件，我的破产案，正式备案。我的债权人将获得价值4911美元的珍本书籍库存，价值750美元的档案信件和纸张，以及40.45美元的现金。我剩下的珍本书籍库存不足以让我作为书商重新开始，但幸运的是，我确实还有修复工具和材料，所以书籍装订将是我要走的方向。
I hope I'll never have to go through other bankruptcy, though that's about as meaningless as someone recovering from a car wreck saying they don't plan to ever crash again. Still, it's unlikely, as one must be in debt to go bankrupt. As it stands now, I will not qualify for any kind of meaningful credit for seven years. I won't qualify for almost any home, school, or car loans, nor for many jobs. And I won't be able to rent anywhere that has an application process, which leaves those cash-only motel-like tenements out by the airport. With such options, I'm hardly in danger of crashing. I'd never be able to build up enough speed. And that, I suppose, is the point.
我希望我永远不必经历另一次破产，尽管这就像一个从车祸中恢复的人说他们不打算再发生车祸一样毫无意义。不过，这不太可能，因为必须负债才能破产。就目前而言，我在七年内没有资格获得任何有意义的信贷。我几乎没有资格获得任何住房、学校或汽车贷款，也没有资格获得许多工作。而且我无法租到任何有申请过程的地方，这让那些机场外只有现金的类似汽车旅馆的廉价公寓成了选择。有了这样的选择，我几乎没有发生车祸的危险。我永远无法建立足够的速度。我想，这就是重点。
Bill Cotter. He's the author of the novel Fever Chart. His story about bankruptcy first appeared on the McSweeney's site at mcsweeneys.net.
比尔·科特。他是小说《发热图》的作者。他关于破产的故事首先出现在mcsweeneys.net网站上。
Our program is produced today by Lisa Pollak and our senior producer, Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Production help from Aaron Scott. Seth Lind is our production manager, Emily Condon our office manager. Our music consultant is Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由莉萨·波拉克和我们的资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·凯尼格、罗宾·塞米恩、阿莉莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。制作协助来自亚伦·斯科特。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理，艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。我们的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ manager and oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, people always ask me, what did he sound like before he got on the radio? I have a recording.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我们节目的WBEZ经理和监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你知道，人们总是问我，他上电台之前听起来是什么样子的？我有一个录音。
"What's the matter for you? Hey, Louie, where's the driver?"
“你怎么回事？嘿，路易，送货员在哪儿？”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week for more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，收听更多《美国生活》的故事。